Speaker 1: There is an absolutely horrifying
viral video out of Los Angeles of LAPD shooting
a woman at point blank range with what is
believed to be either a rubber rubber bullet
or a bean bag round.
There's actually conflicting reports about
this.
We are going to look at the video, the video.
It's sort of graphic.
It's certainly it's certainly disturbing.
It's sort of graphic just as a warning.
And we are going to look at that momentarily.
But first, some reports about this video shows
LAPD officer shoot protester at close range
with non-lethal round outside Koreatown, SPART.
Video shows an LAPD LAPD officer shooting
a non-lethal round at a protester at close
range as the department responded to a clash
between two groups who held dueling demonstrations
outside a Koreatown spar over trans rights
on Saturday.
That was the impetus for this protest.
When officers arrived in riot gear, protesters
started throwing bottles and projectiles,
according to authorities, some of them were
pelted at officers, which prompted them to
issue an order to disperse when some groups
failed to leave less than lethal force was
deployed.
The viral video shows one officer firing the
rubber bullet, hitting a protester in the
stomach she has seen falling to the ground.
The woman's condition was not immediately
available.
There's been another report.
LGBTQ plus activists shot with rubber bullet
in L.A. protest.
L.A. LGBTQ activists gathered to counter a
protest against trans access to the sports
facilities in LA's Koreatown neighborhood.
The video shows LAPD pointing guns at demonstrators,
shooting rubberized bullets, using batons
and pushing journalists.
One counter protester was shot with a rubber
bullet after shouting Don't shoot.
LAPD Captain Alfonso Lopez said in a video
interview shared on Social that police responded
to projectiles being thrown.
He stated the police arrested 38 people.
So let's look at the video.
And of course, what's at issue here is whether
this particular protester I don't deny for
a second that there were bottles being thrown
at police.
I saw videos of that.
I don't deny for a second that an order to
disperse was given.
The question is, why was this particular person
shot at point blank range, which, by the way,
is not the way rubberized bullets are supposed
to be used.
Let's take a look for those who are watching
here with us Joe.
So the woman holding a phone and you see people
rushing over to her as we continue to to to
look at this and at almost point blank range,
just unbelievable video.
And again, it's one of these things where
if there is an explanation for why that's
reasonable, I'm having a hard time even imagining
it because we see what the woman is holding.
Rubber bullets are very dangerous at close
range.
Most police department policies have really
specific rules, like a minimum distance when
these are going to be used or when it comes
to beanbag rounds, I believe it's you bounce
them off the ground or you only target legs
or these are for dangerous, non-compliant
individuals, not someone who has their hands
up saying don't shoot, holding a phone.
And so, of course, you immediately see the
right wingers come out and say, well, she
shouldn't have been there.
There was an order to disperse.
Where are they on that exact explanation for
Ashley Babbette, who was trespassing?
Remember, this was not at the Capitol.
This was out on the street.
And the incredible hypocrisy that we are seeing,
particularly because of this Ashleigh Babbette
Trump riot, January six story makes the crocodile
tears.
Hear about, well, she shouldn't have been
there.
She's just she was breaking.
No, she wasn't, actually.
No, she wasn't.
There was an order to disperse.
And the interpretation of how quickly that's
supposed to happen is much like resisting
arrest, something that police will often use
to start using more force than is necessary
or than is indicated.
Rubber bullets not even being used in compliance
with policy rubber, of course, makes it sound.
It was it's rubber.
It's sort of like if someone throws a beach
ball at, you know, rubber bullets can be lethal,
they can be used improperly and can be lethal.
And I'm not even listen, I'm by the way, I'm
not in favor of shooting the anti trans protesters
or the pro trans protesters.
I don't want any of them shot.
If people are just protesting.
There's another layer here, of course, which
is that there was an anti trans protest going
on outside the spa, which triggered counter
protesters who are pro trans rights.
And it's the pro trans rights counter protester
who ends up getting herself shot.
Somehow the police still ended up shooting
her.
That's just sort of like a detail of I'd call
it irony, but that makes it sound less tragic
than it actually is, but just horrifying,
horrifying video.
And we're still getting more information about
this.
We'll continue to follow it and see what we
ultimately find out.
Again, the protester who was shot condition
I was not able to find anything definitive,
at least this morning when I was researching
the story about what is going on with her
at this time.
But horrible, horrible video.